We're on problem number six and
I actually figured out how
to cut and paste from the PDF
file to my little writing
board, so we actually have
access to the problem.
So it says: What system of
inequalities best represents
the graph shown below?
So we want to figure out what
inequalities represents this
shaded area.
So a good place to start is just
to figure out what these
dotted line graphs, what the
equations of them look like.
So this one, let's do the
hard one first, right?
This is at an angle.
So whenever I look at a line,
I like to think what's it's
slope and what it's y-intercept,
right?
And then you could just write
it in the form y is equal to
mx plus b, where b is
the y-intercept
and m is the slope.
So let's try to figure out the
equation of this line up here,
this dotted line.
So what's its slope?
So when I move over 1 and x,
when I move over to the right,
when x increases by 1, or let's
say when x increases by
2, how much does y increase?
Well, y increases
by 2 as well.
Or whatever we increase x by.
If x increases by 1, then
y increases by 1.
So the slope is 1, right?
Slope is just change in
y over change in x.
So the slope of this
first line is 1.
So m is equal to 1, for at least
this first line up here.
And what's it's y-intercept?
The y-intercept is just what
does the graph equal when x is
equal to 0 or where does it
intersect the y-axis?
Well, it intersects the y-axis
right here at y is equal to 1,
so b is equal to 1.
So the equation of this dotted
line up here is y is equal to
mx, the slope times x, we
figured out the slope was 1,
so that's x plus the
y-intercept, which we also
figured out was 1.
So that's the graph of
that line, right?
But notice, the shaded region
is below that line.
And it also does not include
the line, right?
That's why they drew
a dotted line.
If it was a solid line, that
means that we're including the
line itself.
But the shaded region does
not include the line.
But it's below it.
Think of it this way: For any
given x-- let's pick this x.
Let me do it in a
different color.
Let me do it in blue.
If I were to pick x is equal to
1, this is the point y is
equal to x plus 1.
That's the equation.
Now, my question to you is y
above y is equal to x plus 1?
Is the shaded region y is
greater than x plus 1, which
would be that region?
Or would it be y is less
than x plus 1,
which is this region?
Well, clearly, it is y is
less than x plus 1.
You pick any x, x
is equal to 3.
This is what y would be equal
to. y would be equal to 3 plus
1 if you picked this choice.
But the y's that satisfy the
grey area are always less than
this point.
So at least the grey area
relative to this equation, we
can write the inequality y
is less than x plus 1.
And we know it's not less
than or equal to.
It would be less than or equal
to if they had filled in this
line, if this was part of
the area, but it's not.
They drew a dotted line.
So that's why we know it's
less than, right?
If the grey area was up here
it would be greater than.
You just pick an x, you say,
oh, the y's less than the
line, not the y is greater.
But we're not done, right?
Because this would be the
solution set if all of this
area was grey.
But it's only grey up
to a certain point.
It's only grey up to this
line down here.
This line is easier.
This line has no slope, right?
No matter what my change in
x, my change in y is 0.
So what's the equation
of this?
The equation of this line
is just slope is 0.
So y is equal to 0x plus
the y-intercept.
Well, the y-intercept
is minus 2.
So the equation of this line
is y is equal to minus 2.
Let me do it in the purple.
I'll just write it here.
That equation is y is equal to
minus 2, Which makes sense.
For all x, y is equal
to minus to 2.
Now, my question to you
is this grey area.
For any given x, the y is
greater than the line or the y
is less than the line?
Well, let's pick this x.
When x is equal to 3, y is
equal to negative 2.
That's this line.
Now, is the grey area-- the
y's for that x-- above the
line or below it?
Well, it's above the
line, right?
So if we look at it from the
point of view of this
boundary, we say that y has to
be greater than minus 2.
That's the shaded area.
y is equal to negative 2 is this
dotted line's equation.
The shaded area, at least
relative to this line, is y is
greater than negative 2.
If I just had this by itself,
I would shade up everything
above y is equal to
negative 2, right?
But I want just the combination
of both of these.
So essentially, we have to say
that y-- let me do it in a
nice, vibrant color.
Since the shaded area is below
this line, we know that y is
less than x plus 1.
And since the shaded area is
above this line, we know that
y is greater than negative 2.
Where could I write that?
I'll write it right here.
So which of the choices
satisfy that?
Let's see.
Whoops, I went to the
next problem.
So we know that y is greater
than negative 2.
So these can't-- let me
just cross those out.
That and that can't
be the answer.
And then we also know that
y is less than x plus 1.
So we know that this
is the answer.
And frankly, if you just looked
at the choices, you
really didn't have to figure out
the slope and y-intercept.
They're essentially giving you
the equations of the two
lines, right?
You say, like, oh, one is x plus
1 and one is negative 2,
and I just have to figure out
whether y is greater than or
less than each of those lines.
And you can say, OK, relative
to the y equals negative 2,
we're definitely greater than
negative 2, so I'm one of
these two choices, and relative
to y is equal to x
plus 1, we're definitely less
than that line, so we have to
be choice b.
Next problem.
Which point lies in the solution
set for the system?
So you essentially just have
to say which coordinates
satisfy both of these
equations?
And frankly, you could graph
them and you could draw the
area like we did in the last
one, or you could just try out
the numbers, right?
Let's just try the numbers.
That never hurts.
So minus 4, 1.
Let's see if it satisfies it.
So remember, the first
coordinate is x, the
second one is y.
So 2y would be 2 times
minus 1 minus x.
So minus minus 4.
Now, is that greater than
or equal to minus 6?
Well, this is minus 2 plus 4.
And this is what?
Minus 2 plus 4 is equal to 2,
which is definitely greater
than or equal to minus 6.
So it satisfies the
first equation.
Let's see if it satisfies
the second equation.
I'll do it in another color and
I'll do it up in the black
area up here.
So 2 times y.
So it's 2 times minus 1--
y is minus 1-- minus
3 times minus 4.
And they want to know is
that less than minus 6?
So you get minus 2.
3 times 4 is 12, so
it's plus 12.
Negative times a negative is a
positive, so that equals plus
10, which is not less
than negative 6.
So the first one
does not work.
That is not the answer.
Let's try the second one.
3 comma 1.
So y is 1.
So it becomes 2 times 1, which
is just 2, minus 3.
Is that greater than or
equal to negative 6?
So you get negative 1 is
definitely greater than
negative 6, so this satisfies
the first equation.
Does it satisfy the
second one?
2 times y.
2 times 1 is 2, minus
3 times 3.
Is that less than minus 6?
So you get 2 minus 9.
You get minus 7 is less
than minus 6.
So that is true.
So choice b works.
You don't have to
go any further.
That point lies in the solution
set, which just means
it satisfies both of
these inequalites.
Next problem.
Scroll down a little bit.
Which system of linear
equalities is represented by
this graph?
So now we can use some of the
skills we used the last time.
I don't have much space
to draw all of them.
So let's just to figure out
the-- let's see, do they gives
us-- no, they don't even give
us the equations because all
the equations are different, so
we have to figure out the
equations of these two graphs.
So let's do this top
one first. So let's
figure out its slope.
When you increase-- and you
can just eyeball this one.
When you increase x by
3, y increases by the
same amount, right?
So change in y over change
in x would be 3 over 3.
Whatever you change x by, y
increases the same amount.
So the slope of this first one
at least-- let me do it in a
color you can see over black--
the slope is equal to 1.
And what's its y-intercept?
Well, you just look at where did
it intercept the y-axis?
Right there.
So the y-intercept is
equal to minus 2.
So this first equation
right here is y is
equal to x minus 2.
Fair enough.
And this grey area, is
it above or below it?
It's below it.
You pick any x.
For any x, this is y is
equal to x minus 2.
The grey area is for all
the y's that are
less than it, right?
And notice, now the
line is shaded in.
So the line is part of
the solution set.
So at least relative to this, we
know that the grey area is
all y's that satisfy y is less
than or equal to x minus 2.
Less than because it's below it,
and it's equal to because
they actually drew
in the line.
But now we have to figure
out the lower bound.
What's the equation
of this line?
So let's think about
it a little bit.
This one's a little
more interesting.
If I increase x by 1, so if
I'm going from this point,
what happens to y?
y goes down by 2, right?
1 minus 2.
If I increase x by 2, y
goes down by 4, right?
Minus 4.
So at least in this case, the
slope, change in y, is minus 4
whenever change in
x is positive 2.
Or it could've been change in
y is minus 2 whenever change
in x is plus 1, right?
So it equals minus 2.
And that makes sense.
For every 1 you go over,
the slope goes down 2.
And what's it's y-intercept?
Let's see, y-intercept is just
right there. y is equal to 3.
So b is equal to 3.
So this second graph is y is
equal to minus 2x plus 3.
And then, once again, the shaded
area includes this, but
we have to be greater than
or equal to this graph.
We have to be greater than,
because if you pick any x, the
y's that satisfy the shaded area
are equal to the graph or
greater than for any x.
So there we have
our inequality.
So this one, this area, you
could kind of say is y has to
be greater than or equal
to minus 2x plus 3.
That's from this boundary.
And we also know that y
has to be less than or
equal to x minus 2.
Now, hopefully, that's
one of the choices.
If we haven't a made
a careless mistake.
Let me see.
All right.
y is greater than or
equal to-- OK, so
this is not the answer.
Neither of these are
the answers.
That's not the answer.
Let me cross that out.
y is greater than or
equal to-- we have
minus 2x plus 3, right?
Let me make sure I
got that right.
Minus 2x plus 3.
Yeah, let me see.
Right, so they're tricky.
So the slope on that second
line was minus 2x plus 3.
They got the second
part right.
Maybe I made a careless mistake,
but I don't think
this is right either.
Let's see if we can rearrange.
So these other two, they put
the x's and the y's on the
same side, so let's do that.
That top equation, we
can rewrite it.
Add 2x to both sides.
You get 2x plus y is greater
than or equal to 3.
And the second equation, if we
were to subtract x from both
sides, you get y minus x is less
than or equal to minus 2.
And now this is interesting.
So there's no minus 2 on the
right-hand side here,
but what can we do?
If we multiply both sides
of this equation by
minus 2, what happens?
Sorry, multiply both sides of
the equation by minus 1.
You get minus y plus x.
And when you multiply an
inequality by a negative
number, multiply or divide, you
switch the inequalites.
So it's greater than or equal
to-- and we're multiplying by
negative 1-- 2.
So it becomes x minus y is
greater than or equal to 2.
So our two equations turn into
2x plus y is greater than or
equal to 3, which is this one.
And we get x minus y is greater
than or equal to 2,
which is that one.
And we're done.
It's choice d.
See you in the next video.